La volta al món a peu, dia 243.
Em trobo l'avió que em portarà des de Tbilisi, capital de Georgia, fins a Tashkent, capital d'Uzbekistan,
on després d'uns dies seguiré caminant per entrar ja a Tajikistan.
Però bé, en aquest bloc us explicaré una mica el que faré aquests propers dies fins que no camini per Uzbekistan,
una mica de turisme, alguna història i tal.
Però ara mateix estic en un moment que potser no es repeteixi mai a la vida.
S'ha d'aprofitar aquests moments, que és que estic creuant el desert de Turkmenistan ara mateix
i d'aquí a poc ja passarem a la frontera amb Kazakstan.
I és increïble, el paisatge és totalment marcià.
És a dir, si a mi em posen ara aquí i em diuen
no, no, és que estàs en una nau espacial i això és Mart o algun d'aquests planetes
i m'ho crec, eh, perquè...
Clar, és que no hi ha res, només espècies, no sé, muntanyes, no sé com definir-ho,
muntanyes, sorra, aquests colors marrons.
Us imagineu caminar per aquí?
També seria guapo, potser.
Brutal, brutal.
Tens com unes taques blanques, no sé si serà sal, això.
Brutal.
El mar Caspial hem passat, estava despistat, no l'he vist, però bueno, és un mar, al cap i a la fi.
Ara, de cop i volta, el desert apareix en una espècie d'oasis.
Sí.
De reserves d'aigua aquí, perquè sí.
Enmig del desert, eh, aigua. Flipes, eh.
Bueno, bueno.
Soc molt raro, perquè a mi m'agrada el matge dels avions, ara ens han portat el dinar,
que és arròs amb aquesta espècie de, bueno, mandonguilla hamburguesa,
i després pa, fruita, matalena, és una mica d'amanida.
Bueno, ara cal provar-lo.
Però a mi, en general, m'agrada el matge dels avions.
Gràcies.
Bona nit!
Benvinguts a Uzbekistan!
A la control del passaport m'han vist el passaport i he dit, ah, el Real Madrid!
I jo, no, no, no, Barcelona.
Potser no hauria dit això?
Hauria dit, a la Madrid.
No, però ja està.
Super bé.
Super fàcil.
Pimpam.
i barbetis. What?
Val, a veure, tema...
Què fer ara?
La SIM. La SIM m'han dit que a l'aeroport
el servei, el preu
és molt similar a fer-ho a la ciutat.
I si ho hi... Doncs ja tinc l'internet
ara, per tant, doncs...
Doncs vaig a fer-ho, vaig a fer-ho i ja està.
140 gigues,
5 euros.
Crec que és la SIM més barata
de moment.
Excel·lent. Ara un taxi fins
a l'hotel i després anem a explorar
la ciutat.
Aquí hi ha els taxis normals
i després hi ha el Yandex,
que és com el Volt
que ve a servir a Georgia, o bueno,
l'Uber, el Cabify, el que sigui.
I és... Bé, suposo que és molt més barat
perquè és el que tothom recomana que agafi.
Estic esperant el d'això.
Per cert, la calor és seca
a l'ombra. Fa calor, però...
Es pot estar, però el sol és brutal, eh?
El sol és brutal i és una hora més.
Són les quatre i mitja, això vol dir que són
tres hores més que a Catalunya.
Ja anem, a poc a poc,
desvelant els misteris de cada nou país
pels que vaig. Mira,
allà està el meu taxi.
Comencem bé, no hi ha
cintura de seguretat.
L'he anat a agafar, però està aquí, amagat al darrere.
Bueno, està bastant a prop
de l'aeroport, eh, a l'hotel. Crec que
dos milles, que això són
quatre quilòmetres. Res, un euro
el ride de taxi.
He arribat mitja hora abans
del que els havia dit i no hi ha ningú.
Mira, acabo d'aprendre que
hola en usbec es diu salom.
Salom?
Hello?
Bueno, abans de tot,
per què hi ha una foto
del pont del petroli
de Badalona
aquí a Uzbekistan?
No, segur que no l'és, eh? Però...
Se sembla un munt. Prou bé, eh?
20 euros.
Ara no fem la prova Clean and Iron, això només va ser
a Georgia, però sembla bastant
clean i bastant iron, eh?
D'acord, 20 euros.
Bueno, prou bé.
Prou bé.
De sobres, de sobres.
Bueno, he deixat passar una mica
les hores de més sol i he aprofitat
també per fer una migdiada
perquè aquesta nit he dormit molt poc entre els nervis
i que he hagut de matinar
i he vingut aquí ara a l'hora del
Sunset, a les set i pico,
a la plaça de, espera, deixeu-me tornar a mirar,
Amir Temur,
que és aquest senyor d'aquí.
Bueno, abans d'explicar-vos qui és, dir que
jo no m'esperava gens
que Teixqueng fos així, eh?
Bueno, a veure, estic al centre, però he vingut des del meu hotel fins aquí
i tota l'estona era més o menys igual.
Molt modern, això. És molt modern.
No sé si n'és a les afores,
doncs no sé, hi ha edificis més xungos,
mira, ara s'il·lumina tot.
Però són...
És que, a veure,
aquí també és un país túrquic, no?
Us recordeu que ho vaig explicar
a Turquia?
Però no és com a Istanbul, això.
A Istanbul són turons, és molt caòtic.
No, no, no, aquí les avingudes són molt amples
i tal, i, hòstia,
és molt modern.
És molt modern, Uzbekistan.
Jo no ho tenia com un país així.
Està bé, a vegades,
anar als llocs sense tenir cap idea preconcebuda,
perquè després et sorprens.
Bueno, qui era aquest senyor? Amir Temur.
Bueno, és l'heroi nacional, ho acabo de mirar,
i als anys
més o menys 1400 va fundar un impèrie.
Un impèrie que es deia Temúria,
o alguna cosa així similar.
Un impèrie que era
per aquesta zona de l'Area Central,
i, bueno, pues,
era molt important, etcètera,
i la independència.
El 1991
el van recuperar una mica
com a símbol nacional
i, bueno, són aquestes coses
que,
a l'època de la Unió Soviètica, evidentment,
ningú parlava d'ell,
però, clar, després,
a l'època de la independència de la Unió Soviètica,
doncs, van necessitar una mica
d'amor propi, suposo, i van
recuperar la figura
d'aquest senyor. Molt bé,
està tot impressionant, i el parc, molt maco.
Vaig a fer una mica, una volta més,
a veure què hi ha, encara que, clar,
amb aquestes amigudes tan grans, jo crec que
moure's a peu, no sé si és la millor idea.
Aparentment, això que tinc darrere
és un dels símbols de la ciutat,
l'hotel Uzbekistan,
per ser l'exemple més clar
d'arquitectura brutalista
de l'època soviètica de l'Àsia Central.
I té forma de llibre, diu.
Jo,
la forma de llibre,
doncs, no la veig. Per què? Perquè està una mica doblegat.
I, tampoc, la forma de llibre, doncs, no la veig. Per què? Perquè està una mica doblegat.
I, tampoc, la forma de llibre, doncs, no la veig.
I tampoc li acabo de veure la gràcia. És un hotel gran
i ja està, no?
No li acabo de veure la gràcia.
Segur que té molta història, eh? Segur que té molta història,
però, així com a monument,
veig moltes dones
amb flors.
Sí, mira,
aquí davant tinc dues.
No sé molt bé el per què. Segur que hi ha un per què.
Però no el sé.
Ara preguntaré.
A la IA.
Les fonts de Montjuïc d'Uzbekistan.
Amb música inclosa. He activat la cancel·lació de soroll
perquè és música en drets d'autor. Whitney Houston.
I will always love you.
Però una mica el glamur que estigui
envoltat de KFSs i Burger Kings.
Però, no, és que
estic flipat, eh? Estic flipat. Jo no m'esperava res
així. Brutal, eh?
Els uzbeks.
Els uzbeks com són?
Doncs tampoc jo sabia com eren els uzbeks. Jo m'esperava
que fossin... Semblen els turcs.
Perquè, doncs, havíem dit que era un poble túrcic, no?
Són... Tenen els ulls molt
rasgats. O sigui, rasgats.
Fesomia
que nosaltres podríem conèixer
com a oriental, no?
Japonesos, coreans i tal. Se semblen bastant,
diria jo. Sí, sí, sí, sí.
No, no ho sabia. Pensava que
els kazaks, els de Kazakhstan,
sí que tenien aquesta fesomia, però no
sabia que els uzbeks, també.
Ara estic a un carrer que es diu
Broadway.
O sigui,
còpia del nom, dic jo.
No diria jo que sembla molt a prop, encara que
jo no hi he estat mai.
Però està bé, està bé. Mira, hi ha
aquestes llums que estaria bastant guai
que els ensenguessin.
Fem una cosa, vaig a preguntar. Aquí,
a Uzbekistan,
tenen la influència russa i
jo crec que tothom o molta gent parla rus,
però crec que no parlen molt d'anglès.
Farem la primera prova, vaig a preguntar-li a algú
a veure si saben si s'obren aquestes llums
en algun moment o no.
Excuse me, do you know if these lights
get open at some point
or not?
I don't know. You don't know?
Ok, thanks.
Bueno, a la primera sí que m'han entès.
Clar, estem just al centre
del país, aquest seria el punt més central del país.
Val, també seria
bona idea sopar.
No sé com és el menjau uzbek,
sí que és una cosa que el pan nacional es diu...
Comença per P.
I és un plat d'arròs.
Que què? Potser seria un bon dia per provar-lo.
Poca il·luminació ara mateix.
Aquí darrere malauradament està tancat,
però tenim allà al fons el monument
a la independència d'Uzbekistan
que va ser, com us he dit abans,
de la Unió Soviètica el 1991
i va ser...
Bueno, doncs, no seria
pacífica la paraula que potser s'hauria de fer servir,
però no va haver-hi
una guerra amb Moscú.
No, va ser una independència
i ja està. Després sí que va haver-hi
altres conflictes dintre d'Uzbekistan, però bueno,
ja en parlarem més endavant.
Ara estic caminant des de fa una estona per aquesta avinguda
i aquí a l'esquerra hi ha un parc
on hi ha diverses coses, però clar, falta tanta il·luminació
que...
no es veu res.
Així que
crec que vaig a sopar, ja són gairebé les 9,
no sé quina hora sopen aquí, potser és tard, saps?
L'intenció era menjar el plaf,
que és el menjar aquest
més tradicional, el més típic.
I vinc a un lloc on, sembla que el fan,
sembla que el lloc està bé,
arribo, està més bé del que
pensava.
De fet, el lloc és increïble,
massa pijo inclús pel meu gust, saps?
Em sento una mica desubicat.
I bueno, m'assec i demano el plat aquest
i resulta que no el tenen. Se'ls ha acabat.
Ostres, tu!
Però ara ja no m'assacava perquè
tenia massa gana.
M'he demanat una sopa freda
i això estava boníssima.
Aquesta sopa estava boníssima, boníssima.
Top 10 de menjars de la volta amb una peua.
I després he dit, bueno,
què em recomanes per substituir el plaf aquest, no?
Doncs una espècie de fideus amb carn.
Bé, però normalets.
Vull dir, fideus. Molt gruixuts.
Bé, normalet.
I lo loc és el postre aquest.
El postre aquest que es diu Chak Chak
és això
que està fregit amb oli
i per sobre porta
mel.
És una bomba, és una bomba.
I a veure, tampoc és una cosa
molt loca, però és molt diferent.
Vull dir, mai havia menjat res així.
Bueno, avui primer dia
estic gastant molt, eh? Estic gastant molt.
No paro de pensar-hi. Potser hauria d'estar al dia una mica més.
Hi ha una cosa
que no us he explicat, que és que mentre estava descansant
en l'hotel, he estat gestionant el visat de Tajikistan.
Hi ha
diverses opcions per fer-ho. Una és fer-ho
pel teu compte. Costa un
no sé si 30 o 40 euros.
Però t'has de barallar bastant
amb la web, és bastant random.
A vegades funciona,
a vegades tornen dos dies, a vegades tornen dos mesos.
Clar, jo no tinc aquest temps.
L'altra opció és
anar a l'ambaixada, però he estat llegint reviews,
i l'ambaixada aquesta és un caos, i...
i es veu,
bueno, he llegit, i que no és fàcil.
No és fàcil. A més, avui és divendres,
i només estava
obert als serveis consolars pel matí,
per tant, m'hauria d'esperar fins dilluns, no?
Total,
que he vist per internet que hi ha un servei
d'una agència,
un torperador
de Tajikistan, que et fa tot el tràmit
ell. T'ho fa tot ell,
pagassant per caixa, evidentment,
incluint el permís necessari per anar al Pamir.
Llavors,
he preguntat, i...
eren 190 euros.
190 euros
és una pasta,
és una pasta, però
em garantitza que
entraré, i he pagat.
He pagat. I quan he anat a pagar amb la Revolut,
perquè era
dels pocs sistemes de pagament,
Revolut m'ha avisat tres vegades que
Cuidado, perquè això podria ser un timo.
Que et podrien estar timant. Cuidado, que et podrien robar els diners.
I jo, alarmat,
he anat buscant per internet un munt de
vegades això, si és un timo o no, aquesta agència, tal,
si són legits, si són legals...
A priori,
tot el que he buscat, sembla
bé, sembla que no m'han de timar.
Evidentment, avui és divendres, ells no podran
fer el tràmit fins dilluns, no?
Perquè també per ells el consulat està tancat.
Potser m'han timat 190 euros,
així, per la cara.
No sé,
no sé. Ja ho descobrirem.
16 euros ha costat el tema.
Bé, tenint en compte
el restaurant pijo que era,
està bé. D'acord,
ara agafaré el metro.
El metro de Teixquén.
A veure, la parada més propera.
El meu hotel
està a dos quilòmetres
de l'hotel.
Llavors, Enric, per què agafes el metro?
Sí, el que
tenia més sentit és que agafessis un taxi si dius
que és tan barat, no? Aquí tenim el metro.
Sí, però,
es veu que el metro de Teixquén
de per si ja és una
atracció turística. Es veu que és un dels metros
més impressionants del món.
Perquè cada estació és una obra d'art, o
alguna cosa així.
I s'ha de veure, s'ha de veure.
I, bé, no ho sé, aniré,
després caminaré dos quilòmetres per baixar una mica
el sopar o el que sigui.
A veure què tal. No tinc ni idea d'on va aquest metro.
Aquí no va com el Google Maps
com la resta del món, que tu dius, vull anar aquí.
I et diu, sí, agafa aquesta línia, agafa tal
i et portarà cap aquí, saps?
No. Aquí no funciona el Google Maps
i no sé
on estic anant.
Aquesta estació està bé, però no és res impressionant.
Segur que n'hi ha altres de millor.
No sé on estic anant.
Jo crec que faré una cosa. Baixaré la que tingui millor pinta,
l'enviaré, sortiré al carrer i agafaré
un taxi.
Bé, gràcies al mapa
que hi havia dintre del
vagó, més o menys
m'he pogut orientar. L'he preguntat
a l'AIA, és que què faríem sense l'AIA, eh?
L'he preguntat quina és l'estació més maca
i m'ha donat tres i ara anirem a una
d'elles, que es diu Cosmonautas o alguna cosa així
que va de l'espai.
Aquesta, que és així com bastant ràndom, mola també.
Hi ha aquestes rajoles
hidràuliques.
Doncs sí que està guapa, sí.
Té com dibuixos de, suposo
que astronautes russos, no ho sé.
I...
aquesta rajola així
de colors brillants i el
sostre aquest, que també mola bastant.
Molt bé.
Molt bé, molt bé, molt bé.
M'ha agradat.
M'ha agradat, m'ha agradat. Ja en tinc prou de metro.
Vinga, anem a casa.
Doncs ja estic a l'hotel i me'n vaig a dormir.
Que tinc son. Estic cansat.
I, a més, demà m'atino molt
perquè me'n vaig a Bokhara.
Ja està, Enric. Ja deixes t'esquent tant que t'està agradant.
Sí, bueno, com sabeu
jo tinc una mica de pressa per creuar
les fronteres altes d'Alta Jekistan
i el Pakistan.
Llavors aquí a Uzbekistan no m'hi estaré
gaire. I si he
d'escollir on passar la major part del temps
prefereixo passar-ho a Bokhara,
Samarkand
i potser algun altre lloc que m'han dit que està bé.
Ja veurem.
No me'n recordo com es diu.
Sí, Tashkent està bé però
crec que la gràcia són les ciutats aquestes
més històriques i més tal.
Llavors he decidit agafar un tren demà a les 7 del matí
i
anar fins a Bokhara.
Demà és dissabte.
Bueno.
És igual.
El fet, ja us explicaré més a partir de demà
què faré.
Que tampoc ho tinc clar ni tan sols jo.
Què tal aquest tipus de videoblogs?
No és massa habitual.
Jo sempre faig els vlogs caminant,
caminant en matxeco, no sé què.
I ara és turisme de mochilero,
que és bàsicament el que has fet per a Uzbekistan.
Bueno, tu, és part de l'aventura
també. I és això
o que no hi hagi vídeo.
Per tant,
faig això. El que potser sí que faré
a Samarkand i a Bokhara
són més vídeos d'aquells que jo parlo
amb una veu de fons i us informo
amb més rigorositat de les coses
que no el vlog de
oh, que maco això, oh, que maco això.
Que també està bé, eh? Però
crec que l'altre és una mica més enriquidor.
Vale. Ja està.
Recordeu que no hi ha podcast fins d'aquí
a dues setmanes perquè el Sergi està una mica liat.
Bona nit.